madame monsieur bonjour des caméras dans
les avions
depuis quelques jours en effet les tout
nouveaux airbus d'air france sont
équipés de caméras qui permettent aux
passagers d'assister au décollage en
direct mais aussi pendant toute la durée
du voyage de voir les paysages qui
défilent sous l'avion
ce système à terme sera développé pour
permettre d'améliorer la sécurité à bord
patrick esther et olivier thiêt ont fait
le voyage paris philadelphie pour les
passagers qui montent à bord de cet
airbus 330 long-courrier flambant neuf
rien ne semble particulier est pourtant
sous le nez un petit hublot inhabituel
protège une caméra c'est elle qui permet
de suivre en direct sur des écrans vidéo
y compris en classe économique
tout le vol caméra savoir quand
quelques-uns notre jeu permet
paradoxalement loin de se sentir
espionné par 211 paires d'yeux les
pilotes apprécient plutôt le système
vous voir le roulage de voir le
décollage de voir les villes s'envoler à
c'est un spectacle en temps réel
certains passagers ce qu'on a envie d'y
penser que c'est un film qui passe et on
peut même aller peut-être un peu plus
loin
d'avoir des angles de prise de vue
différent des choses comme ça on peut
tout inventé serait avec le numérique
maintenant effectivement avec cette
technique il va devenir possible de
placer d'autres caméras sous l'avion
c'est ce que recommande d'ailleurs le
rapport d' enquête sur l'accident du
concorde
les pilotes étaient dans l'incapacité
visualiser l'importance du feu sous
l'appareil je pense qu'une vue notre
environnement dessous est nécessaire
nous on a des informations qui nous sont
présentés mais qui nous donne qu'une vue
parcellaire de la situation par exemple
une roue qui éclate nous on se rend
compte à plus de pression dans la roue
le fait de l'avoir et dans quel état
être un atterrissage c'est encore autre
chose
dans le cas de l'avion géant comme le
futur a380 ce système sera même
incontournable l'avion à surveiller va
devenir va devenir énorme et les
problèmes de communication sont
compliquées et une caméra est
indispensable pour savoir où en est les
chargements même la cabine
l'arrière de l'avion il me caméras de
télésurveillance pourra même être
installé dans le kop philippe connecter
sur les boîtes noires ou interrogeable à
distance par cet ennemi
elle permettra de lever le doute sur un
éventuel détournement rien à cacher de
mon travail je suis pour si ça peut
aider à faire avancer la vérité à
améliorer la sécurité
vous savez qui est actuellement on a
déjà des enregistreurs de conversations
si une caméra c
hélas pour un peu ça me dérange
absolument pas après les événements du
11 septembre les autorités de l'aviation
civile américaine envisage de rendre
cette caméra obligatoires